hello folks
welcome to rational science
directly from frankfurt germany
the only site on the internet that does
physics
everybody else does math
they call it physics anyways uh today on
our show we're gonna have
uh three parts first part we're going to
do a little bit of
extinction quite popular subject really
and second part we're going to do a
little bit of physics today we're going
to
be dealing with schrodinger's cat is
that cat still around
is he dead or alive i mean let's find
out right
and then the last part we're going to do
questions and answers of
questions uh really and comments that
people made since the last time
now incidentally i usually don't answer
things real time and because some of the
questions that people ask
require a an elaborate answer
and so i want to give them a good answer
and for that you really
want to investigate what the guy is up
to sometimes they put up
you know a link or sometimes they say
talk about the subject and you don't
know really what they're referring to
so uh you know you got to do a little
bit of research to
answer the questions correctly anyways
once a month i do get together with my
son and we do
real time live questions and answers
okay let's get on with it uh with
extinction
and the subject of today the first
subject
comes from a person who put a comment
and he says diversity of species already
on the downgrade
before the asteroid hit earth
and another fella doubled up on them
says
uh there's an article about the
cretaceous extinction
on br german tv station it seems
mainstream science is catching up
uh-huh so uh i looked it up
uh see what they're referring to i i
guess they were both referring to the
same article maybe they
read the same article they came out
about a week ago
and this is the article let me get it up
here
article um yeah what is it the
29th of june 30th of june it says
dinosaur
biodiversity declined well before the
asteroid
impact influenced by ecological
and environmental pressures
okay and so they go on and and they
mentioned
what happened about 10 million years
they looked at the last 10 million years
prior to the cretaceous the kt
extinction
dividing line which was anywhere they
don't know exactly it's 65
million to 66 million years ago
somewhere around there
i want to call your attention to uh one
of the
persons on the list there and that's
that third one
michael j benton okay he's kind
of like the dean of paleontologists
in in in this realm in the kt extinction
also permian and so on
he's been around for a while and he
wrote a paper
a 30 year old pen i have discussed him
in the past but
he wrote a paper uh 1990
okay which i recommend that anyone who
wants to
you know come into the field and just
get an
overview i think it's an excellent paper
and that paper is deals with the history
of extinction theories okay here's the
paper
scientific methodologies in collision
the history of the study of the
extinction of the dinosaurs
and it's a good paper because he does a
pretty good job of going through
and figuring out you know what the
different theories were throughout time
so uh you know it's like a must read for
anyone who gets into this subject
anyways uh he essentially puts
two models or two groups of people we
have the gradualist
on one side and a catastrophist on the
other
the gradualist is a person who says you
know these things happen
over time the loss of diversity of
species the decline the
slow decline of
in other words they were losing
more species as time went by and
the causes uh are assigned to
competition
declining temperature marine regressions
the last two
primarily from a fellow named as robert
baker i've talked
about him in the past and baker
wrote a book which i also recommend the
dinosaur heresies
very good book primarily because um
you know he does a lot of theory in
there he goes into mechanisms
i don't agree with uh some of baker's
conclusions especially
uh but the book is is good anyways it's
a good read
very thick book but it's a good read why
because um
baker goes in there and again you know
goes into mechanism
which is what it should be you know for
anyone who enters this field
anyways uh benton uh contrasts the
gradualists against the catastrophes
and who are these people well they
believe as far as the dinosaur
extinction
that it all happened through an impact
of an asteroid
okay and it goes in there says dust
cloud which blocked out the sun
prevented photosynthesis okay and so i
guess
all the plants died or something like
that in fact some people say that
exactly that
and so it's got to do with uh the
atmosphere
and also with thermal stress and i
synthesizes that
synthetize it at the bottom you see it
there on the left hand side i said
competition and climate change is
essentially
what the gradualists propose and the
catastrophes
propose catastrophes and environmental
changes sudden
changes okay so this is essentially the
fight
you could say between uh that's been
going on for a long time
i would say since the days of george
kuvir
200 years ago we had these two groups
some people who say it happened
gradually the extinction of animals the
otherwise said no it happened suddenly
okay and so who is right
uh do we have enough facts to determine
who is right okay
that's one of the things you want to
keep in mind today anyways
um i
don't think uh mr benton
wrote anything important after that he
never contributed
anything at all other than that paper to
paleontology
he said bill how can you say that what
are you saying
this man's uh been around for so long
he's a paleontologist he's
an expert in his field
and before we can really say that in
sign authority we have to figure out
what a paleontologist is what is
paleontology what is paleontology about
and uh here we look up a definition and
we find in the national geographic the
study of the history of life on earth
as based on fossils wikipedia
says the scientific study of life that
existed prior to
and sometimes including the start of the
holocene
epo uh includes the study of fossils to
classify organisms and study their
interactions with each other and their
environments okay and you look at
dictionary.com says what is a
paleontologist
it's a scientist who specializes in the
study of life forms
that existed in previous geologic
periods as represented by their fossils
is that what a paleontologist is is that
what
paleontology is about
and no the answer is no those
definitions are not scientific
and i'll tell you why
science is not the study of
it's not the study of anything science
is about explaining
you have to explain something so you
studied
and you know nothing you understood
nothing does that make you a scientist
you studied for the test on friday
and you got every question wrong you got
a zero on your test
does that make you a scientist because
you studied
people have this notion that came from
the 17th century so-called scientific
revolution
that says that uh you know
science is an ongoing process
no absolutely not science has nothing to
do with a process
science has to do with explain something
that's when you have to burn your
calories up here your gray matter but to
say that you studied
and then you come up with some uh
nonsensical
theory explanation
mother nature laughs at such science
so-called scientists
and so no what is a paleontology what is
this uh field about well here it is
paleontology the branch of science that
rationally explains
extinction okay paleontologist is a
medical examiner he's a forensic
pathologist
a scientist who determines the cause of
death
of ancient species in other words
extinction of plants
and animals okay that's what a scientist
is especially a paleontologist right
paleontology you have to explain depth
you have to explain
how animals in the past died
and or plants as well and if you cannot
explain that
what do i care if you studied you
collected stuff
you know some people have this idea that
paleontologist it's a guy that goes out
there in
the middle of nowhere and starts
breaking the rock
pulling bones out dusting them off
assembling them giving them a fancy name
and putting them in a museum
uh no that's not a paleontologist as mr
ernest uh rutherford would say that's a
stamp collector
paleontologist has to tell you something
about the death of animals and plants
and animals in the past
once we're done with that we're done
with paleontology for the rest of
humanity for the rest of our
history or the rest of our existence
and anyone who wants to go in there look
at more bones
and classify them they can do that that
part
is very specific and those are
specialists who dedicate time to that
the important thing from paleontology is
extinction
once we got that people don't want to
hear
all the little details about
measurements and how
how big the tooth was and all these
things that you know
that you see in the literature out there
we need an extinction theory
and we don't have any extinction theory
on earth today
okay for 200 years we've had this
discipline
known as paleontology and not
one person today can tell you how the
woolies
willy mammoths became extinct how
neanderthal became extinct how the t-rex
has become extended how the mammal
reptiles became extinct
no one has a theory of extinction
a fool-proof extinction and you say well
there's lots of theories out there l
i mean what are you talking about
there's only one thing
that an extinction theory has to explain
and that is selectivity if you have not
explained selectivity
you do not have an extinction theory and
if you don't have an extinction
extinction theory you're not a
paleontologist
we have no paleontologists on planet
earth
today and part of that has to do because
you know
all these people they go through the
courses at the university and if they
want to graduate
they can't buck the trend they have to
tell the party line
they have to publish whatever the
previous generation who are the peer
reviewers uh want them to publish
so even if they have a bright idea out
of the norm they can't publish it
because
they would be considered uh you know
outside
the norm no you can't buck the trend you
have to tell the party line
if you went through that channel see in
my case i don't have to worry about that
because
i don't know these people anything i can
give you a theory
and does that mean you're going to
believe it no that's not the point
point is that i give you a theory so
that
you can think about it so you can reach
your own conclusions
but i'm not going to just repeat what
all these people do which is what the
previous generation has already figured
out
proved and all they do is regurgitate
from one generation to the next the same
thing
over and over and over again we've had
the same theories for the
last 200 years okay and
uh so here's this theory these people
came up with
okay see if i can get this up here okay
and this is what they say in that paper
the most important part probably that i
you know sifted out the question why
non-avian
dinosaurs went extinct 66 million years
ago remains
unresolved
already their paper starts out on the
wrong foot they're saying we don't know
after 200 years we still have no idea
why the dinosaurs died
they're telling me that in the first
sentence of the paper
okay so let's see the biodiversity of
non-avian dinosaurs
would have been declining 10 million
years before they were finally extinct
apparently a gradualist here right not a
catastrophist okay but but
it was the impact of an asteroid that
killed them off
[Laughter]
i like that you know uh you got to be
at peace with both uh god and the devil
okay so you shake hands with both of
them you know and you say uh yeah mr
devil i
shake your hands in case i have to
happen to go to
hell and i'll shake hands with god as
well you know
okay the mighty asteroid which today is
testified by the
chick salute crater in mexico in a thin
layer of iridium all over the world
would have changed the climatic
conditions
of the earth so abruptly that the
habitats of the non-avian dinosaurs were
destroyed
so what is the what are these fellows
going to talk about well you're going to
talk about
an asteroid that caused some climatic
catastrophe some some sudden
change in the climate possibly
you know the dust that covered the
entire earth that blocked out the sun
that
uh prevented photosynthesis or normal
photosynthesis
okay so this is where this uh this paper
is going
the climatic conditions okay it says the
non-avian dinosaurs did not have the
necessary biodiverse
and evolutionary tools to recover as a
class from
the asteroid impact you have to
give you know pay homage to the asteroid
theory
otherwise you don't get your paper
published that's how simple it is
see i don't have to worry about that
because uh
i don't i don't suck up to all these
people
so i can give you a theory and uh yeah
you gotta find it uh
like a needle in a in the youtube
haystack to find me but once you get
here
uh at least you're gonna listen to
something that you can sink your teeth
into
and so okay so it says uh
they could not recover a combination of
global global climate cooling
okay the uh diversity of herbivores and
an
age-dependent extinction had negative
impact on dinosaur extinction in the
late cretaceous
these factors impeded what their
recovery
from the final catastrophic event
meaning the
asteroid so they couldn't recover
otherwise you know they would have
recovered
this is what they're suggesting uh like
many say if that
asteroid hadn't hit the earth in fact
someone said that
in one of the comments the asteroid
hadn't hit the earth
uh the uh the uh what is it the
dinosaurs will still be around in new
york city
my god okay let's find out
um what's wrong with this
uh because here they're saying the last
10 million years
there was a decline in species some of
them because apparently the hadrosaurs
expanded that's what they're going to
argue their numbers expanded at the
expense of
others okay but what's the issue here
the issue here is the uh little fable
that i tell
about uh then the last five neanderthals
and yeah it's a fable because uh the
neanderthals were animals
and so i think i'm okay by saying it's a
fable so you get the last five
neanderthals on earth
and they're in a cave and they're around
the campfire
there's this big boulder rolls down
and kills all five of them
okay so now someone asked well bill how
did the dino
how did the neanderthals die
and i said they died by rock they rocked
a boulder fell on them that's how they
became extinct
now is that a valid theory no it's not a
valid theory because you have to explain
how we ended up with five neanderthals
that's the extinction theory
not the nonsense that a boulder just by
sheer luck fell on their heads
that's more or less what we've got here
that these people here in this paper
they say
for 10 million years these folk the
dinosaurs were declining
and then came this uh asteroid i don't
know where god's
got an act of god you know got through
the asteroid
to the earth and uh just wiped them out
you know the straw that broke the
camel's back so to speak
well no we don't care about the asteroid
because if the asteroid fell
to the earth it couldn't have been the
cause of the
demise of the dinosaurs if the dinosaurs
were
becoming fewer and fewer and fewer in
the last 10 million years we have a
little contradiction
the theory is how did we end up with few
dinosaurs
not what was the boulder that killed
you know the last financials that's not
a theory
and so we have to find out why the real
cause of extinction has to do with
why we ended up with fewer and fewer
dinosaurs
that's the theory okay and um
so yeah i got a problem with first uh
this
middle uh position and second to cover
all the bases
well it was climate change it was
competition it was also the asteroid you
know we put them all together and boy
that paper's got to be approved by the
peers because everybody's happy
you know the peer who believes in
climate change he'll like it the guy who
believes in the asteroid theory he'll
like it
you know everybody likes it and what is
all this for is this for science
or is it to get your name in lights
so that you can make more money make a
career
and see this is the problem we've got in
science in general
paleontology in particular and that's
that
you know you have to bow down to the
previous generation
and so it turns out that the working
hypothesis
the the foundation always starts from
the previous generation
you can't buck the trend because you
don't get published you don't have a
career you don't have any money
if you want to be up there you want to
get your name and lights you have to
start you know first by paying homage to
the previous generation
and so we've got a series of this for
200 years now probably less than that
but
certainly after world war ii we've had
all these theories
where one guy just depends on the other
guy and depends on the other guy who
depends on the other guy
and so we can never get out of that
because the system
that we've created for science does not
allow for new
theories for new uh proposals
that's the problem and so you're always
going to hear the same thing over and
over again
from now on it's going to be well the
aster was not red it was blue
it was a little bigger was a little
smaller and we measure this little
i mean what is that that's science the
theory is
what how did the dinosaurs die did they
die by
comet or did they die for 10 million
years gradually
which is a theory and when you put it
all in there it's just
all you're doing is sucking up that's
all you're doing okay
so how do we explain extinction in
comparison
in contrast here at this site okay we do
it a little more rationally
okay and so we start by mentioning the
following
these are this is how mother nature does
extinction
okay and she looks at the vitals
what i call the vitals breathing
drinking
eating sleeping and aging and
loss of genetic diversity those are the
things that
none of us can avoid species cannot
avoid
okay in other words you need to breathe
and i think we can take that one for
granted even though
paleontologists out there you know the
ones who believe in supernovas
they say that the air was taken out of
the earth momentarily
uh waited for some of the animals that
died in the air came back the air came
back
and uh you know we received this big
shot
from a uh supernova it comes from nasa
nasa loves all these extraterrestrial
causes
because you know they've got a big stake
in it
and so they give money to all these
researchers
to give to provide extraterrestrial
evidence proof so that they can continue
the cycle
that's what it's all about there is no
chance whatsoever
of an extraterrestrial uh especially a
supernova you know um
having caused any of the of the
extinction in this case it was the
ordovician
okay okay but those are the vitals
that's what mother nature's gonna
tackle she's gonna get you to one of
these and we're we're gonna
eliminate breathing because we're saying
hey breathing i think that's
until someone bottles the air i think
we're all safe there okay
uh sleeping well again i think that's
not
where where the issue is aging yeah
uh aging and low genetic diversity
those are the causes of a background
extinction
neanderthals and uh for us
and for all mass extinctions drinking
and eating
and yeah one of the reasons that um
none of these paleontologists today
have figured out that we are the last
generation of humans on earth
if because they're blindsided they have
no clue
what causes extinction see if if they
would have figured out
how extinctions happened in the past
they would realize that we are the last
you
we are the last humans on earth i mean
how long do we have to go i don't i
don't think we we have 30 more years to
go i don't think we'll make it to the
mid-century that's my personal take on
that
i can't tell you i can't give you a date
but we're about to become extinct as a
species
all mammals in fact the whole order
essentially will disappear
uh this this century for sure there's no
way we can survive this century
and why well because mother nature is
going to attack us through what
drinking and eating two vitals
if you don't eat you're gonna die if you
don't drink
you're gonna die so it's a guaranteed
thing if
that if we remove eating from all humans
on earth
if we remove drinking from all humans on
earth
all humans on earth will die believe me
don't take my word for it but believe me
okay
okay so um how does the
theory start well i usually like to say
that
imagine you're at the starting line
of the cambrian 542 million years ago or
thereabouts
uh obviously there were animals before
them pre-cambrian but
let's start at the cambrian line just
arbitrarily not important
we can predict retroactively now
okay we can predict what's going to
happen retroactively because we've
already mapped it out
in big in general terms in the big
picture we have the big picture
we don't need any more evidence we've
got
too much evidence as it is we already
have the evidence we need to determine
what caused extinction okay and if
you're standing on the cambrian starting
line 542 540
million years ago and you look forward
you can predict retroactively right you
can predict
that periodically plants are going to
disappear
when not if but when plants orders
entire orders
disappear the animals that forged
a relationship a million for millions of
years right
uh relationship with those plants will
disappear with them
now why have the so-called
paleontologists
figure that out well because the worldly
wisdom among them
is that well you know an animal just
switches
from one fruit to another so if he can't
find
uh this kind of food uh you know
especially a herbivore can't find
i don't know grasses he'll switch over
to some other
food some other plant that's that's the
worldly wisdom and what they're saying
is that you know you have a rabbit
and he this rabbit cannot find lettuce
and so he's going to switch overnight to
pine leaves christmas trees
is that true is that how it works do
rabbits switch
from lettuce to pine leaves can
rabbit digest conifers
and no the answer is no the animals
don't switch at the last
moment when something happens in the
environment they say oh i can't find
some of this i'll eat some of that it
doesn't happen that way
can you eat something that can you eat
connors can you eat ferns
the answer is no we don't eat ferns we
don't eat uh conifers
we eat angiosperms okay
and so now imagine an animal
i don't know in the permian and permian
had
really two big extinctions the first
half
they had all these uh sail backs um
lizard like looking animals like
adaphosaurus and
demetrodon second half they had
other types of mammal-like reptiles
which were like the gorgons and the
pariosaurus first guys looked like
lizards the second guys looked like
lions and tigers they laid eggs
lion laying eggs yeah that's more or
less what it was
so um there was an extinction 252
million years ago
so they say that that's more or less the
the
date they've got and it turns out that
you know uh
one of the plants that covered
essentially most of the planet was the
glossopteros there's glissopterids uh
there were different species of these
but they covered the land they were seed
ferns
okay and when these plants
went away just by sheer command and
since
the land animals also went away
now there's a better kuwait citizens
then you got the dry acid you have
dichrodiums
another seed firm which was the end of
the seed ferns by the way
and that's when the arkasar era came to
an end now that's another coincidence
isn't that
and yes it turns out that all mass
extinctions
have uh a major
uh plant that is grow
slowly essentially dying towards the
last few million years
and i caught the um shrinking island
theory
the island of the um
jungles the forest of whatever is
shrinking
and the animals the herbivores that that
depend
on those plants you know they they
cannot diversify they cannot expand they
cannot radiate like it did millions of
years earlier
their forefathers now it's the opposite
direction
now they've grown big through koch's law
cope's law means that animals grow big
through this arms race typically over
time so they become big
they become numerous they have fewer
children
okay and so what do you have well you
have
first the density dependent issue okay
density dependent birth rates
then you have the expansion of big
animals that
are growing and expanding on a shrinking
island
the the uh the jungle
of what they eat right is shrinking and
they're expanding
and so yeah at some point there's got to
be a crisis okay
now why did the plants disappear why are
they shrinking
is it because of climate change like all
these people say
is it because an asteroid or volcanoes
hit the the earth or sprouted
plumes from underneath the ground i
don't know geysers
uh they can only think of catastrophes
it never occurred to them that plants
have their cycle too
all plant species all orders
must disappear you say how do you know
that bill well we know that because
that's the history of life on earth
and here let me show you the history of
life on earth in a nutshell okay here it
is
okay this is these are the this is the
big picture
okay what you have is uh the
carboniferous you had all these
amphibians
and it was the age of uh maybe
nonvasculars and early vasculars
when you get to the permian triassic you
get the age of
ferns and seed ferns uh the age of
synapses really of
mammal-like reptiles then when you get
to the
jurassic and cretaceous you get the
dinosaurs what did they eat
well what do you think they ate if the
land was covered by
uh gymnosperms conifers
and what do we today well what's out
there well what's out there is
angiosperms that's what we eat we don't
eat gymnosperms
and we don't eat ferns because there was
a type of animal that
thrived with ferns another type of
animal that's dry that thrive with
gymnosperms
and you say well how did these disappear
i mean
you know was it by magic uh was it
again some kind of
uh climate change which is the only
thing these people can think of
because it's very popular today you know
in our world you say oh climate change
we got to do something about it
so all they can think of is climate
change and they know they they're going
to get their paper published because
they
just mentioned the word the term climate
change
and so this this is all they can talk
about and no here it is
um let me show you
this is the mechanism okay called
overturning of the demographic pyramid
okay and so yeah when the demographic
pyramid
of plants overturns of orders of species
even of individual plants uh that's when
they die
that's when they become extinct so
plants periodically became extinct when
they lose genetic diversity
they've been inbreeding for millions of
years right they've been
sending their uh pollen or whatever
cones or
spores right so they've been inbreeding
for millions of years
now the amish have been doing that for
300 years and now they're having all
kinds of physical and mental problems
okay after 300 years they started out
with what
a few hundred
and today they're like three hundred
thousand and yeah now they're starting
to have problems
and this is what happens to the planets
but in a million year period
what happens towards the end you know
their population pyramid overturns
because again they become big
one of the clues become big old
they live the long ages nothing kills
them anymore they become
accustomed to endemic diseases
okay they manage to uh
reach a um
a you know a truce with the diseases
that
used to kill their forefathers those
that survived had defenses passed it on
to their
offspring and you know by the time you
get to the end
not only in these plants are no longer
migrating
they become sedentary they're in a
region of the planet that's when they
make their last stand they're big
typically
uh they're resistant to diseases
because they're you know the endemic
diseases no longer kill them maybe
makes them sick at most and they also
begin growing vegetatively instead of by
seed
okay so what happens is the population
pyramid of plants overturns and guess
what happens to the animals that
depend on that shrinking island well
they disappear
and that's the overturning of the
ecological pyramid for
the animals okay and that's what we're
proposing
and i presented this uh in a
paper sponsored uh
there was a conference sponsored what
was in 2016 by oxford university in
prague
czech republic i presented that paper
there
i also presented the paper six years
early in 2010
in aberdeen scotland uh but nobody reads
it why because
uh i'm not part of the establishment and
certainly i'm not going to talk about
climate change asteroid strikes
or any other extraterrestrial strike
competition never even mention it has
nothing to do with extinction
no this has to do with internal it has
to do with the vitals
it's an internal thing to every species
and it's going to happen to you know all
it has happened will happen to all
species that
managed to survive the upcoming
extinction
very soon which is the extinction of the
mammals
okay okay so uh
that's the theory and that's what i
propose in exchange
to what these people propose um
let me show you that they had also uh
a lot of evidence already i mean they
they could figure this out they never
did i don't know why
here's a cretaceous terrestrial
revolution this was
what happened during the cretaceous and
it took them like four years to assemble
all this information so this is pretty
solid
evidence i think so for those who
like evidence well here you have
evidence what happened
during the cretaceous well what you see
is the angiosperms
muscled aside the reigning plants the
conifers
that's essentially what happened okay
not only the number of species but the
quantity of
individuals you could say right quantity
of plants
also it changed the landscape was it
because
of climate change no absolutely not as
you can see there to the
conifers they had grown all the way to
cretaceous and then they
followed what i what i call the curve of
life
okay here's here's the curve of life
okay
this happens to all life essentially
that's the curve of life
and it goes to a peak and then it comes
down
first part millions of years when
they're battling
diseases especially and predators and so
on
well you have births that are greater
than deaths or approximately equal
then you get to the stage where births
are greater than deaths
then when you the pyramid starts
overturning this is the population
pyramid
births uh are less than or equal to this
and finally you know births are way
uh fewer than this that's the curve of
life
and and that's what happened here okay
this this what you see
there that's the curve of life right
there for you look at the conifers you
can see how they have that little hump
there
and that'll give you an idea of uh
what happened in the cretaceous well the
conifers were slowly dying slowly i mean
in millions of years
right uh the the what was expanding were
the angiosperms
what do you think the mammals were
eating well what do we eat today well we
eat angiosperms
so we radiated with the with the
angiosperms and the only reason we could
not
grow too big as the dinosaurs would
probably eat us
but once the once the dinosaurs were out
of the way
hey you know we could expand with what
with the expansion of the angiosperms
and the conifers just were left behind
and it turns out that they got paid in
time because that's exactly what they
did
to the ferns see at one time it was the
ferns that covered the planet
who displaced them the conifers so it's
a fight of plants okay
the plants uh kill the other plant
muscle aside the other plant
partly and the other part is that the
others plants
essentially suffer an implosion they
have to
go through this curve when they get to
the top they start coming down
all the animals which are on that
sliding curve hey they go down with them
and that might take 10 million years
sure okay
but then where does that leave the comet
well that leaves it in fairy tale land
in alice in wonderland okay that's where
the asteroid belongs okay
here's another sample of what happened
in cretaceous this is in the seas okay
and here you see the forums
the forums uh at the kt limit uh
they were the old ones they followed
cope's law they became the dinosaurs
of their world they were big and you can
see the forums that replaced them
afterwards they were small because what
they start out small they radiate and
they become big over time
in general terms that's the what the
curve of life looks like
okay so uh yeah
we have to we have to look at
other mechanisms for extinction and
right now we have 200
years in which we have no the
paleontologist so called paleontologists
have no idea what's over what causes
extinction
okay so now you have another theory to
ponder
do you believe it not important uh
beliefs
are not part of science and science we
explain so that you understand
you reach your own conclusions in your
own dark basement
okay uh what's interesting is that in
that paper they say the following
okay i said the analysis showed that
herbivores tended to disappear first
among dinosaurs
yeah it should be like that but he says
herbivorous dinosaurs of all things
could be responsible for this
the group of hadrosaurs which were also
herbivores were extremely successful
as a group and would have displaced the
other herbivores
i don't know i have a another paper
out there and it says more or less the
following
says that the campanian which was a
million years or so uh before the uh
end of the cretaceous the end of the
cretaceous
uh you had several species of ceratops
you know like the triceratops and so on
and several species of hydro sauce and
by the end of the
cretaceous there were fewer
okay so this is what another paper says
this is the picture and so you say well
bill
who is correct who is right here i can't
tell you who is right i can tell you
that these people
the people wrote those other papers uh
they went to
hell creek montana where you know
apparently the dinosaurs made the last
stand the big guys like t-rex and
triceratops and they did a study and
they
this is the conclusion they reached and
so you have some people who say
these folks the of this newspaper saying
oh no the hadrosaurs
uh muscled everybody aside and the other
people say no the hadrosaurs also
disappeared uh
gradually who is right i don't know
i can't tell you which one is right i'm
just telling you that science is not
about numbers
science is about telling me what the
cause of extinction was
and if you're gonna put all the uh
all the ideas in one basket just to get
your paper approved and say well i'm
gonna
um pay homage to the asteroid guys i'm
going to pay homage to the climate
change guys also to the competition guys
and
and you know all these you know you got
to be uh
at peace with all of them what is your
paperwork what is the cause of
extinction
see i gave you a cause of extinction i'm
saying it's the overturning of
population pyramid of plants followed by
the ecological
pyramid overturning of the ecological
pyramid
of animals so you have a
direct cause of extinction the animals
essentially
they didn't starve to death like
overnight but they were they were
becoming
smaller in numbers older having fewer
kids bigger
etc in a shrinking island and that's
what eventually
ended up killing them at some point they
had to go there was a crisis and they
went
asteroid had no role whatsoever
in mass extinction okay another fellow
brings up another issue and that's
related to the neanderthals
and so let's go with that it says i'm
curious how you would contest
the last 30 years of research on the
genetic admixture of neanderthals and
denisovans
in sapiens also raids and rape also
occurred
well what is this about well i talked
about the neanderthals the other day
okay and what did i say that said that
the neanderthals did not mate
with us i don't think we made it with
the
denisovans either okay but for the last
30 years as you say
all they've been talking about is
inbreeding interbreeding
in fact it wasn't even 30 years okay
it's actually for the last 10 years
since uh svante pablo's and richard
green's
seminal paper on uh on the genome
and he found somewhere close to two
percent
commonality between neanderthal dna and
ours
so what does that tell us that's a
number that's not a
cause that's not a theory so they say oh
we have a theory oh what's your theory
the theory is that we got that two
percent by
interbreeding with the neanderthals and
yeah i have a big problem with that
because
you know animals in the wild don't
don't breed don't interbreed especially
we have to determine whether the
neanderthals in us we were the same
species
or the same race within a species where
we the same race or we were
maybe different races but within the
species
or were were we two different species
meaning that we could not have
successful offspring
if we integrate that's one issue
and so yeah we got a problem because
these people are saying that in the wild
we just went out there and had a lot of
fun
that's very hard to believe because the
worst the enemy
of a neanderthal was another neanderthal
and the worst enemy of a human was
another human
in the jungle there are no friends no
one trusts anyone
so when you see another human on you
know on the other side of the river he's
your enemy he's
he's hunting in your grounds
so you better do something about it
because if you don't he will
that's the way it works in the wild and
to say that these people
you know got together had parties drank
beer and swapped
squaws uh you take my squad a day and
i'll take yours
and that they did it with a neanderthals
that were so
differently uh you know you look at
their
structure their skulls and so on showed
it the other day
you know they're very different in fact
uh an ethel did not have a chin like we
have
they had these protruding brows big
noses
they were smaller have bigger ribbed
cages they were different
just by looking at them you can tell
they're different and you don't have to
be an expert and
you're saying that we did not recognize
them as different
especially when they were nude probably
the woolly man because that's what
neanderthal probably was a woolly man
like you know you have the willie
rhinoceros you have the
woolly uh elephant which is the
uh where's the mammoth
and yeah i think uh neanderthal was a
woolly man
and here we were we were coming from
africa going up there why
because we were probably following the
herds
and so we go up there to their hunting
grounds so they're
we're playing on their home turf they're
used to the cold
they have no shoes they have no clothes
they never invented clothes they never
had needles and here we come in there
we're freezing because it's cold so
start we start
probably inventing clothes at the time
and
we encounter these uh neanderthals they
see us clothed
and we see them like maybe gorillas and
we're gonna have sex with them
uh think again okay so yeah i got a big
problem with all that
okay um so here's uh
the papers that you'll find and i just
pulled
four of them at random just for you to
see and what do they all do well the
same that these other
policies they have to bow down to and
you know
pay homage to admixture and so all
they've been talking about for the last
10 years is that mixture
so it's not surprising that people say
what mixture has been proven it's been
around for so long
again 10 11 years now uh proven because
before that was improvement it was
proven
by swanton pablo when he put out his
genome genome uh
paper okay and so now everybody you can
see there
what do they all talk about they talk
about gene flow and
you know the geneticists have taken over
paleontology neanderthal paleontology
much like uh
alvarez took over uh you know uh the kt
paleontology in other words the
extinction of the diner so you say you
guys don't know anything let me come in
there
he was a bully alvarez is known as a
bully
and and yeah it's important to know uh
also that
a little in retrospect maybe i should
mention that and and i did mention
i have a video on that as well by the
way but
you know uh where did this guy uh
alvarez uh come from well it turns out
that
albert was a guy working with the
military
and he was working closely with a
manhattan project with a
bomb okay and he did some work with
um quantum some quantum nonsense and
because of that his friends
you know got him a noble and when they
got him a noble uh he was used that
uh to trash the paleontologists
who dealt with the extinction of the
neandertha of the
dinosaurs and so he came in there and he
officially trashed a
fella known as dewey mclean
louie trash dewey
and because dewey was a proponent of the
volcanic theory he had to do the same
thing they did with the permian saying
that the deccan traps in
india caused the extinction of the
dinosaurs and
uh and essentially what what's his name
uh
alvarez came in there just trashed and
said no you don't know anything get out
of here
and i just bullied him around slap [ __ ]
slapped him
so to speak and and that's why today we
have the
asteroid theory and yesterday he comes
essentially from his son walter alvarez
they worked as a team and did they come
up with a theory no
well the theory was around at least
since the days of
lauvenfeld in uh what was it in 1956 and
even love himself max levin phil didn't
come up
with uh this theory either the theory
was
you can trace it all the way back to the
days of george kubia
french guy um around that time i can't
remember his name now
he already said extraterrestrial impact
must have caused the extinction of these
animals that they were finding out for
the first time in those days
and so the extraterrestrial impact has
been around for 200 years
so what did the alvarez contribute well
they contributed
what we don't use in science evidence
we have no use for evidence evidence is
used in religion to persuade
to convince to recruit that's what
evidence is used for that's what the
prosecutor introduces evidence into the
record
so he can convince the jury to vote for
his side of the case
that's what evidence is for and but
unfortunately today in science they give
more importance to evidence
than the theory they don't care about
theories that's why we ended up with
idiotic theories and mathematical
physics
uh physics uh you have what a particle
can be in two places at once
the bending of time is gravity what
nonsense is that
they say oh we don't care about that we
don't care about so what do you care
about well we hear about evidence we go
to the lab we look at
we observe we measure we get a number we
have an equation we publish
that's what we care about so they don't
care about theories and same thing with
these paleontologists they don't care
about theories they have idiotic
theories
and what uh albers did he came in there
he came in there and says well i've got
evidence
and he was a physicist with a noble i
mean how much more authority than that
do you need put it behind his son
got him got his name in lights so it's
known as the alvarez
theory or hypothesis or whatever okay so
uh that's where we are and uh i showed
this the other day
this is the problem here you see uh how
they fudge around with the percentages
okay um spontan pablo said
one to four percent you have prover who
says uh
one 1.5 to 2.1 then you have lose in
france they say three to seven percent
uh percent nuclear dna that we have uh
today from the neanderthals
and then you have these other folks over
there that say hey you know
we before 50 000 years ago we had more
than 10 percent
and then we lost it over time okay and
then uh
the other folks there that i mentioned
daily uh
they said greater than two percent and
what do we find today
uh well we found that uh there's this uh
boostisham
uh human uh chrome magnum uh i guess you
could call it chroma he was in russia
but uh forty five thousand years ago and
he also had two percent just like we did
and so uh
no there is no evidence that we lost
from ten percent to two percent
over all these years today we found a
skeleton
dated to almost 50 000 years ago that
has the same percentage as we have today
and
you know they play around with these
percentages
and after a while you don't know what to
believe
and especially because they don't have a
theory and the theory that they have
they have to explain how the
neanderthals
did it with us in the wild okay
did the neanderthals come in and rape
the women
our women our co-magnet and women or was
it consensual did we have a party and
drink beer and swap
squash is that the way it worked how did
it work please explain how we do it in
the wild
especially when we're talking about
starvation subsistence
level creatures they'd live day to day
like a lion you know maybe they
once every three days but then they
gotta go out on the hunt again and hunt
something else because otherwise they're
gonna starve they know
how often they have to hunt and they
hunt in their grounds they
they probably mark their grounds you
know maybe pissing in the trees or
whatever leaving their scents
like warning others hey watch out this
is my
hunting ground and you think a human is
going to come
in there start hunting on their grounds
and having sex with their wives
or vice versa i don't know
you better think again okay people who
who talk about that kind of stuff or
nonsense such as that we traded
seashells a guy like john hawkes says
that
that we traded seashells for who knows
what for
spears for sex for what do we trade for
a piece of meat
nonsense total nonsense that's all you
read about in paleontology today
why because there are no new ideas why
because it's
it's a system you have to publish what
the previous guys already
proved you have to use that as a
foundation as a basis otherwise you
don't get published
that's the way it is and so we've gotta
we we've got a wrong uh
system for developing science theories
explanations rational explanations okay
here's the uh
national geographic and what did he say
about the
you know denisovans says ancient girls
parents were two
different human species oh maybe they
made a big
fuss about this 2018 couple years ago
not long after modern humans left africa
they likely began breeding with
neanderthals
today around two percent of dna from
most europeans and asians is neanderthal
yeah what they never tell you see if
they told you that
you would start suspecting but see they
always let it die by pocket veto
it turns the american indians and the
papua new guineans
have more neanderthal
dna than europeans or africans for that
matter
but they never explain that and they say
oh that's interesting that's that's
quite stunning to discover that
yeah don't tell me it's stunning explain
it because if you're going to explain
your theory based on the fact that
europeans should have more
neanderthal dna than the africans
great no problem okay you prove that
great we prove them we got a proof
evidence now explain the other evidence
why the papua new guineans who never
set foot in europe have more neanderthal
blood than
than we do then europeans like me
european origins or the american indians
how did the
american indians end up with more
neanderthal blood
did the neanderthals go to the sioux or
the apache and
have sex with them as well is that how
we they got it
so yeah this is the problem the problem
is that it's selective
information that they feed the public
because if they
if people out there knew that the
american indians and the papua new
guineans have more neanderthal blood
than the
than the europeans a lot of people start
questioning
okay anyways hints of denisovan also
remain
four to six percent of modern
melanesians
uh genomes come from this ancient home
so how did the uh what is it melanesians
how did they ever
end up with uh what is it up to six
percent of the nissan
dna please explain the mechanism
did these humans have sex with the
denisovans and then go to
melanesia again
again these people never explain
how uh in interbreeding happened in the
wild
and that's what we want to know that to
you we want to understand how that
happened please
uh show us the film step by step how
that happened
that's what we then we would believe in
your theory
right okay or even give it any credit
whatsoever
okay here's another one uh again dennis
evans here you have denny
oh good old danny she was a denisovan
mitochondrial dna which was found to be
fully neanderthal indicating she was a
daughter of a neanderthal woman remember
this is a denisova okay
a nuclear genome revealed her father to
be denisovan so she's
a half breed okay between denisovans and
neanderthals
okay and um but with some neanderthal
ancestry
well you know it makes you wonder
was it her father a denisovan or a
neanderthal
okay because there was some neanderthal
ancestry
and what does pablo say to that he says
uh
when these groups met they actually
mixed quite freely with each other
it was love love in the wild
they all had parties they all got
together say ah let's forget our
differences let's forget the fact that
we've got we've marked our county
hunting grounds
let's all share this willie that we
hunted
cost the life of my grandfather he was
there as well but
why don't you join us in and let's all
eat together and have a party and have
sex
is that how it happened i mean you look
at the chimpanzees today and
the troops invade another troop and they
kill them all they kill all the males
and the youngsters the old ladies and
they take the girls
they're not stupid the young girls they
take and and then they uh
enrich their dna
okay so uh that's how a lot of this
happens in the wild
it happens through violence probably
rape
but not rape like you know again
a lone person out there having sex with
a gal
or whatever that's not the way it
happens the way it happens is
uh if they're you know it can't happen
in in that way
because a female would not leave her
clan
beyond shouting distance
because you don't know not because
you're going to find the neanderthal out
there that's going to rape you but
because you don't know if you find a
lion
running out there so you have to be at
least with it you know there's no 9-1-1
no phone so
you have to be more or less within
shouting distance you can't leave your
clan too far away
any of the members because if he's out
there he could be struck by anything
and if he needs help the other guys have
to come in with their spears and help
him out
so if there's a bear or whatever they
have to kill him
and so the guy has to fight as much as
he can until
he has some help and so no one left a
clan too far away
they when they went out there they went
out to the hunt
together they went together they came
back together
some of them with half a limb but uh for
sure uh
you don't leave the clan so there's no
opportunity for rape
in the middle of nowhere it doesn't
happen
now it could have been you could say a
one-night stand
will that cause the demise of the
neanderthal the disappearance of the
neanderthals
no in order for the neanderthals to
disappear every
last one of the neanderthals had to have
sex
with humans because if they have sex
amongst themselves
we would see a neanderthal today now at
some point
at some point all neanderthals had to
have sex that
you know had babies right had to have
sex with humans
otherwise the neanderthals would not
disappear is that what happened
we mingled uh with all these cavemen
you know they just welcomed us into
their crawls
we went in there and just embraced and
said let's share our bounty and
obviously you know uh the neanderthals
did not go south because
you know they were like the polar bear
they lived in the arctic
they had enough food for themselves
if anything humans were following some
kind of herd and ended up in europe
they were the lines migrating the
neanderthals were more or less sedentary
they had no reason to go anywhere
because they had the food right there in
front of them
they had maybe you know mammoths and
buffalo and whatever they hunted so they
had no reason to leave
on the other hand the humans were coming
into their territory and i'm sure the
neanderthals slaughtered
the first humans who encroached under
lands which again
must have been just a little party of uh
you know clan that ventured in there in
the wrong place at the wrong time they
got killed
the only time humans were able to really
get into europe was when the
neanderthals were
out of the way how did they die their
population
pyramid overturned their genetic
diversity disappeared
they were clones of each other in the
end and you know again
we had this uh overturning of the
population pyramid
okay so let's see all the evidence we
have from the denisovans
okay here it is this is it i didn't
write this okay i just copied it
okay it says scientists have extracted
all we know about denisovans from what
from just three teeth and one pinky bone
i didn't write this this is what we have
from the denisovans
so we have four bits of um
information a little more in the sense
that they did a genome on
one of these and you know they were able
to figure out that
these uh denisovans
were different species
and from this this meager data we've had
at least 10 years or so of
theories of opinions really
and and they all have to deal with the
same thing that we interbred with them
they interbred with the neanderthals the
neanderthals interbred with us
why because they could never figure out
how the neanderthals disappeared
and we have the same situations with the
kt extinction today
they cannot give you an irrational
theory of how the neanderthals
disappeared or how the woolies
disappeared
and so it's either us we killed them we
interbred with them we out competed them
because of climate change
famous climate change what else can
these so-called paleontologists think of
if they have to parrot what the previous
generation bequeathed to them
and if they don't do so they don't get
an advisor for the
phd thesis and they don't get to publish
their career is over so they have no
other
choice but to you know bow down and pay
homage this is the problem
it's it's the system we have for uh
determining
uh for coming up with theories and again
if someone comes up with a new theory he
doesn't get published
they won't allow it so you'll never hear
of any of my theories out there because
you know i'm not part of the mainstream
okay so uh let's continue here with the
denisons some interesting stuff that
you'll see out there
they published a paper i think was in
russia and uh this is
the little piece we got in the west they
found a needle
in the denisovan cave which is over
there close to mongolia okay
and the needle is seen as providing
proof
that the long gun denisovans named after
the cave
were more sophisticated than previously
believed oh yeah if they can
make a needle like that three inch and a
half needle
with a little hole in it man they must
have been very sophisticated
we have found needles before but in
younger archaeological layers
says one of the discoverers of the
needle
yeah i think there's been a lot of
contamination where
you got layer 11 layer 3 and they kind
of mixed them up so we don't know where
that needle came from really okay
but they say this needle came from a
layer that dates to
you know sixty thousand what i think
it's uh
forty five thousand years ago i can't
remember the date somewhere in there
90 000 years but is it 50 000 years ago
okay
okay it predates by some ten thousand
years an intricate modern looking piece
of polished jewelry
bracelet made of chloride by the
denisovans
what are they talking about what is this
bracelet
well here's your the bracelet okay
here's the bracelet and you make up your
mind if these people
are talking any sense anymore this is
the bracelet
bracelets showed the denisovans to be
more technologically advanced than homo
sapiens
or neanderthal scientists found that a
hole had been drilled in part of the
bracelet with such
precision that it could only have been
done with high rotation
drill similar to those used today
and people believe this stuff this is
the this is what's incredible
needle 50 000 years ago or so
bracelet now that quality there you know
i mean uh
what do they have jewelers uh who made
these things
how did they do it with their stone
tools i mean these guys were
approximately in the age of mustering
technology which is what neanderthals
used
and these folks are telling you that
they had the ability to make these tiny
holes
in a needle and to mold such a beautiful
piece
of bracelet of stone there right
in such a way that's even polished right
so what can i tell you if you believe
this you might as well believe in
alice in wonderland okay
so this is the problem and here's in
comparison
you see there there's this competition
who's the first to discover
what oh i'm the first to discover the
needle oh no no you're not because i
discovered another needle which is
predates yours and here's the cebudu
needle okay and this is from south
africa
okay and again it says the cebudu
polished piece has use
where reminiscent of that on bones
experimental used to work animal hides
these people are suggesting that 61 000
years ago
where this needle was found in that
layer in that
reference frame okay
was used for sewing south africa now
would they need clothes in those days
uh in south africa
well i don't think so you know i i think
that um
here we're talking about you know
probably some kind of
uh human maybe neanderthal level human
or maybe
heidelberg level you know you have
rhodesian man
he's the heidelberg counterpart in
africa
or so they say and so here's this uh
animal essentially you know living in
the wild out there and he's going to
sown
clothes what for why does he need
clothes
i think that we invented clothes and
needles
when we started venturing into europe
and
for sure we won't find a needle among
neanderthals
they never did i mean here you have all
these sites
they found natal bones they found all
their
lots of their tools they never found a
needle
among neanderthals you would say with so
many sites
they found all these bones they found
all these skeletons they found animal
bones etc
they never found a needle you know a
little
even i don't care if it's three inches
or whatever it doesn't matter but
with a little hole inside the wood
inside the bone
they never found that and they never
will because
neanderthals did not use clothes they
had no use for needles
any more than you know uh i don't know a
polar bear
has used for uh for clothes either
so uh yeah it's it's all this nonsense
that these people publish
why because they want to get their names
in line they want to get be the first to
find the needle so it's a competition
for finding needles
and everybody forgets about the theory
nobody talks about the theory they just
talk about the fines
that's the problem okay another fellow
who raises uh
well let me show you something else here
um
one fellow raises this issue about
um the neanderthals being in
israel in iraq in syria
in the levant in this whole area middle
east
and i'm saying no the animals have had
no reason to go down there
i mean what did they do uh do service
camel jockeys down there
uh you know nanda though was a polar
bear he lived in the
arctic weather that's what he was used
to he didn't wear clothes he didn't wear
sandals
he walked in the snow he slept in the
snow just like wolves do today
wolves sleep in the snow and this animal
who's
a polar bear is going to venture all the
way south
when he's got all this food up there all
these mammoths and
buffalo that us humans our forefathers
went there to hunt in their territories
so we go up there and now these people
are going to come down
these these neanderthals they're going
to come down to israel
no i don't think so okay i don't think
it uh it ever happened
is there a problem with the sound
let me see here
am i having a problem with the sound
please confirm if there's a problem with
the sound i hear someone has a problem
with the sound
i can't hear you anymore
someone says audio works oh
could have been because i show all my
number
i keep having this problem somehow
youtube doesn't work has a problem
okay okay thank you let me continue here
okay um uh here's uh
just for those who want to look uh this
uh issue up okay here's aaronsberg
and he's more or less an expert in the
middle east
uh neanderthals okay and this is what
they have to say
this paper was from 1998 but it i think
it's still strong but you see they try
to
push these papers underneath the rug
okay but he said there is actually
little evidence for the existence of a
southwest
asiatic neanderthal population
in israel during the middle paleolithic
paleolithic period
human fossils originally labeled as
neanderthals were subsequently
uh reevaluated and defined otherwise so
people have problems distinguishing
between neanderthals and humans
obviously
parts of bones they say oh it's an
endless it turns out it's a human
so they have all these errors out there
and you got to be careful about all this
because
again they want to make extraordinary
claims okay
and it says a horizontal mandibular
foramen which characterizes 61 percent
of the neanderthals is absent in
and they mentioned three sites so uh
if you read that paper you'll find a lot
more uh arguments
they're saying that the um
that the uh fossils that they found in
the levant uh are not
uh neanderthals there's too many
differences between the
neanderthals or the bones the fossils
they found over there compared to the
ones they found in western europe in
spain france belgium germany
those over there are different are
noticeably different than those over
here
so i think what we're talking about is
two different species there's another
species out there running around maybe
there were several
you know uh maybe there were different
types of humans
that originated in different parts from
uh the homo erectus who apparently
walked
all the way east to china and all the
way
uh west from africa right all the way
west to england
so you know from there it's very likely
that the denisovans came out
maybe in the middle of russia maybe some
others came out
uh in uh somewhere in the levant and
then you had
us us humans our forefathers who
apparently came from africa
there could have been several uh
humanoids in different parts of
the world except in americas in the
americas
they haven't discovered america columbus
had not discovered america yet
okay just one final note there here we
have the the
derriere and this is origin is thought
to be
a neanderthal child
and i look at it and it doesn't look
like a neanderthal at
all to me at least okay now you can say
bill you're not an expert okay i'll
concede that but all i can tell you
is that other paleontologists think the
same thing says two individuals of
burial number one and number two share
many neanderthal
anatomical features but display several
differences in some traits as well
in the cranium and dentition the dead
area 2
would be expected to have more
definitive
definitive neanderthal features which
are commonly found
in the european classic neanderthals and
they go in there and
uh if you look at the paper it goes into
more detail of the differences
and so all i'm saying is that you got to
be careful because
these people talk about the neanderthals
the levant
neanderthals the ones in israel syria
and iraq especially
and i don't know if these were
neanderthals in fact
i dismiss them they're not they can't be
they can't be not because
i don't agree with them but because i
cannot imagine neanderthal being born in
the arctic like a
polar bear and walking all the way to
the equator
to do what when he's got all the food he
wants up there because humans went in
the opposite direction
because they were probably starving to
death and they were walking into
neanderthal territory
maybe following the herds maybe seeking
i think it's got to do with food
any way you look at it okay another
issue that someone raised
there's zero possibility that the
women's consent would be a factor
talking about rape or consent right
whether sex was consensual the
neanderthal could just kill all the
males and abduct the females of course
after all the males were dead the women
would rather go with the neanderthals
and go
not go with them because if they didn't
they wouldn't be able to survive
okay so uh that's how the women got
trapped
and so i can show you is my take on that
and here's a okay was it case of rape or
you know did the nether just take the
girl and
take him to take her to his cave or was
it that she went voluntarily you know
just uh
flirting with him is that how it
happened and how about us how did we uh
deal with the women over there well
maybe we probably ran away
when we saw a neanderthal woman that's
that's my take on this
i sure pity uh any human uh forefather
of mine that
is one of these so-called neanderthal
women and uh
either he had bad eyesight sorry in the
night and then woke up the next morning
he said oh my god
this is this is what i slept with
okay so yeah uh the way i look at it
this is this is these are two
possibilities why we ended up with two
percent
okay we either had sex fifty thousand
years or so ago forty five thousand
years ago
or the two percent comes because we had
a common ancestor
very likely homo erectus
we do have footprints at least of some
bipedal animal in england
800 000 years ago and so we have to
assume that there were
homo erectus in western europe
from there the heidelberg came and from
there came the neanderthals that's my
take on that
so neanderthal was born as far as i'm
concerned in europe
he had no reason to migrate out of there
he had enough food
he was a cold uh climate
animal uh gorilla some kind
and we on the other hand we were nomadic
why because we couldn't find enough food
or maybe we were just following the
herds and we ventured into europe
why did we come in what maybe 35 000
years ago
because by that time the neanderthals
were dead we're no longer around
other than that the neanderthals would
have killed us would have murdered us
uh our forefathers okay
um
one fellow says this is the punchline
says lentils didn't disappear they
became politicians
well i disagree with that as well i'm
saying they became
people who are known today as
paleontologists
okay what are my conclusions well here
it is uh conclusion the disciplines
neanderthals cro-magnons
no you know they as far as we're
concerned
these never met or intermingled or had
sex or married
there's no evidence that cro-magnons uh
where in europe
uh before 35 000 years ago there's no
evidence that
neanderthals disappeared for
um lived beyond 40
000 years ago in other words the
neanderthals died 40 000 years ago we
came into europe 35 000 years ago what
am i saying
that's the objective data at least as
far as humans are concerned
right now all we can trace to any
level of the to any degree is that we
were in europe maybe 35 000 years ago
maybe a little earlier maybe
38 000 years ago we were there just
about the time that the neanderthals
were about to leave
mosterian technology dies 40 000 years
ago
if we listen to tom him he's the expert
in dating fossils okay
uh there's no skeletons or skulls of
denisovans all we have is a what a pinky
and uh what is it three uh
uh three bones three other bones there
that's all we have we don't have
anything from from the
from the denisovans almost so we don't
know what they look like
we have no skeleton we don't have no no
skull okay uh paleontology but it
doesn't matter anyways uh
again you have to explain the theory how
did the neanderthals
uh mate with the denisovans how did we
mate with
either of those two species that's what
you get explained in the wild
if you can't explain that i don't care
how much commonality you find in our dna
there's other explanations for that and
one of them of course is that we had a
common ancestor
way back when 800 000 years or so ago
okay paleontologist geneticists make
outrageous claims to
what for careers money and fame
geneticists are go first
that's all they are is fonte pablo a
uh gen a uh scientist he's a geneticist
but he's a geneticist
a scientist well not if all he does all
day is count
atoms you know i mean he's got a machine
that does the counting forum and he just
compares base pairs and so on yeah
that's that's
a gopher type of work that's lab uh
work uh the scientist sends
the lab boy to do that kind of work says
go count atoms for me and give me
the results so swanton comes back says
here boss this is what i found uh so
many base pairs how many
molecules okay you can leave now let me
think i'm going to figure out
what happened a scientist is a detective
a guy who tells you
what happened these people
you know they're they think that because
they can count atoms
and do some fancy footwork with
genetics that they're scientists well
the fact that they can count atoms the
fact that they determine
that two percent commonality between our
dna and neanderthal dna
does that allow them to conclude or
extrapolate that
we had sex with them i mean what should
we conclude with
chimps who have commonality with us as
well i mean we have commonality even uh
with a fruit fly if you go
far back enough so how did we have sex
with the
with these animals in the past if we
have commonality with them
is that what we're going to conclude
that because there's some commonality
with the dogs we had
sex with the dogs or the cows what is
this
nonsense you have to come up with a
mechanism
a theory of how that happened in the
wild out there okay
um admixter created a cottage industry
for whom for the geneticist
because they took over the neanderthal
extinction business and today it's all
nonsense it's all about
oh what diseases we inherited from them
what diseases we gave to them
how much dna do you really have from the
neanderthals everybody goes out there
and say oh check my blood i want to know
how much
neanderthal blood i have in me well you
should come to me i'll tell you have
right off the bat without any machine
you have at least 50 percent
neanderthal blood in you and probably
comes all from your mother
okay it is known as political science
that's what these people are doing
they don't do science they do political
science a lot of politics that's all it
is just uh
getting your theory through so that you
get your name and light your career up
and running your money your fame that's
what it's all about
it's got nothing to do with science with
extinction theories
they don't have they don't have an
exchange of theory for for
the end of the world is for the kt
extinction they don't have a
theory for permian they don't have a
theory for any not one that will
that will that will stand
the the rationality
okay permian what is it volcanoes okay
great volcanoes so how did volcanoes
do selectivity how did it kill these
animals
chronologically older animals and leave
the new animals alive now that's a smart
very smart volcano can do that right
okay admixture has yet to explain how
animals in the wild smoke the peace pipe
okay so yeah don't tell me that we did
it
tell me how it happened in the wild
that's essentially it
okay let's get on with uh schrodinger's
cat a little overdue sorry i extended a
little bit there but
lots of questions i wanted to make sure
i covered a lot of these
uh little details okay we've been
talking about what uh
incoherence oh i'm sorry they called it
d coherence i call it incoherence
quantum
incoherence what is that well particle
had two places at once
now how rational is that photon is
simultaneously
both an extended wave and a point
corpuscle
it's known as duality complementarity
both at the same time it's it's that
before you measure it then it collapses
to one or the other
in fact in the case of um the photon it
always collapses to
a a particle it never collapses to a
wave because a wave is a verb
can't collapse to a verb it's got to
collapse to a noun turns out the photon
is not a noun either
photon is what it's zero dimensional
whatever and that's not much of a noun
there okay so yeah that's uh incoherence
for you
uh we've covered that a couple weeks ago
uh here's entanglement what came after
that here's entanglement a nutshell
entanglement particle here affects
particles there
without physical mediator there's no
physical mediator one is going cl
counterclockwise the other
clockwise then they switch around and
the other one instantaneously
turns in the other direction as well and
there's no physical mediator
how did it do it uh magic
black magic is that what we're gonna
call it yeah it's instantaneous action
at a distance and they could never
explain they never will
how do you explain it with particles
with discrete particles how do you
explain action at a distance
how is a particle affected by another
particle if they're all separated by
space
well that's easy all you say is well you
put more particles in between they come
out of space that
turn into two particles you know space
is made of two particles space is
nothing so we have black and white
particle and
they get together and they form a no
particle and then the no particle
divides into a black and white particle
that's great tell me the process tell me
the mechanism how it does it how mother
nature does that magic trick
if you can't explain that you've got
nothing you
you just spent saliva
okay then we came up last time around
with superposition what superposition
well the horse gallops and stand still
at the same time
how does that happen how can a horse run
even if in the same place okay i don't
i'll concede that okay
here's the horse running in the same
place and at the same time
time standing still like a statue
what sense does that make how can you
picture that
i mean i i try to picture it but uh
i'm very creative
no you cannot imagine a particle that
vibrates and it doesn't vibrate at the
same time
makes no sense to say it's vibrating and
not vibrating
until you measure as soon as your
measure collapses to one
or the other of these states quantum
states
so all these are they're nonsense that's
what they are
and uh so here we have uh where they
come from
all this from this gentleman niels bohr
okay principle complementary
and that's essentially the foundation of
this thing that they
shorten to duality you know
light is both a particle and a wave at
the same time they don't say it like
that they say it behaves as if
well you're saying in different words
that it is
because that's what you're simulating
what you're saying with you're saying
here's a particle here's a wave
until i measure then it collapses to one
or the other and it
always collapses to the particle that's
the duality and what does this uh what
did
good boar say well he said essentially
it's an essential this
complementarity it's an essential
feature of quantum theory
okay and objects have pairs of
complementary properties which cannot be
observed or measured
simultaneously specifically they're
talking about what position
and momentum uh energy time
they have a couple of these dualities
out there okay
they they like all this stuff because
they say uh it gives them something to
work on gives us
job security okay measuring one quantity
of a pair for instance the position of
an electron
excludes the possibility of measuring
the other for example
moment impossible to have a sharp
separation between the behavior of a
system
and its interaction with the measuring
instrument
that's what complementary is all about
in other words they have no
clue or like uh mr feinstein
said uh in the 60s he said uh no one
understands quantum mechanics and what
is he saying
he's saying if you don't understand it
you cannot explain that means you don't
have a theory
so you're not a physicist because a
physicist is a scientist and a scientist
is someone who
explains if you cannot explain in the
case of physics a mechanism a cause
you are not a physicist if you cannot
explain
how magnetism does its magic if you
cannot explain how
a particle can be at two places at once
you can explain how
uh time warps
in general relativity right and
then you haven't said anything because
we're interested in the house and why
and
the causes and mechanisms that's what
physics deals with
not with math you know equations
descriptions
okay uh here we have mr heisenberg he
put in the other grain that comprises
what we know is the uh
copenhagen interpretation a child
uh brainchild of uh mr bohr says there
is a limit to the accuracy
with which the position x and momentum p
of a particle can be predicted from
initial conditions and he came up with
this
equation that says the more you know
about one the less you know about the
other
okay so this is one of the foundation oh
these are foundations of quantum
mechanics
this is what these people believe this
is what they people
spread out there and this is how they
explain these are the physical
interpretations that they're giving you
okay that's what we need to
you know wrap our brains around these
are the physical interpretations
so here we say we try to measure here
and because you can measure here uh
you know you don't know what's going on
over there and einstein said no we
should be able to know what
what's going on over there because if we
can determine the position here we
should be able to
without measuring we should be able to
know what's going on over there
and you know bohr came back with an
answer to that but
essentially this is uh what uh
heisenberg proposed he says
you know the more you know about one the
less you know about the other
position versus momentum i like to call
it
uh as follow because what is position
location
what is momentum it's motion so we have
location and motion
and so they say the more you know about
location the less you know about motion
and vice versa
i know kid you know if the ball is
standing still
it's not moving and if it's moving well
it's not standing still
and the funny thing is they had to come
up with an equation to explain that
and so this is the way i like to put it
here's a good old heisi
and uh says when the ball stands too it
doesn't move and when the ball moves
it doesn't stand still yeah no kidding
do we need an equation to understand
this so
this is what uh heisi proposed
and so uh you know uh you have uh
einstein and his buddies podulski and
rosian they came up with us
let me get back in here in a second here
and
he came up with this uh paper 1935
uh with his buddies podoski and rosen
and they criticized
the copenhagen interpretations what are
you people saying
are you saying that you know we cannot
measure exactly and einstein's arguments
that
even if we don't measure hopefully
what's occurring out there mother nature
is in control of that
she knows what's going on maybe we don't
know
we don't know how to measure we don't
know how to take that measurement
you know in the microscopic world but
hopefully mother nature father universe
the devil one of those guys has to know
what's going on in reality again so they
said quantum particles must have
position
and momentum even without being measured
and so quantum mechanics must
be an incomplete theory it's known as
the in
incompleteness argument that raised by
einstein his buddies
the far away particle must have precise
values of both
quantities whether or not that particle
is measured in any way
that's essentially his argument what did
bohr say
well he came back with a stunning reply
he said well
i need you're wrong measuring momentum
does not allow the observer to
automatically
transfer or extrapolate right this to an
inference
of position of the other particle
so this is what he's saying just it just
is that's the way it is
and i said i had a problem with that
because he says you know that doesn't
make any sense and uh board just replied
well
we're not supposed to make sense in
other words uh we're not supposed to
understand
uh the common sense of mother nature
that's essentially what his argument was
and so you have schrodinger and
schrodinger was a buddy of
you know the einstein and all these
other folks he said
this is what the copenhagen
interpretation is saying
what these people are saying is uh that
um and he put it in classical terms he
put it in terms of
macro items and the famous schrodinger
cat and he says look a particle is
merely a probability function that's
what
he was saying that this is what the
copenhagen folks were saying okay
shortening care is cat is an analogy for
a particle
so we're gonna use a a real object such
as a cat
to explain to illustrate what these
people are saying
in quantum just in case you missed it
okay the particle is described by
a wave function it's described by a wave
function
so they're talking about an equation
what is an equation a verb
it's not a noun the equation is a verb
it's just
it's a snapshot or
coded way of presenting motion
that's what an equation is okay so
equation is always a verb
the way we the wave function proposes
that a
quantum particle is spread out and
occupies all of space
okay so here we have this wave function
it occupies all
of a space it's like the cat occupies
all of space
schrodinger's cat okay the this
distinguishes it from classical
from the classical corpuscle because the
classical particle
looks like this yeah it looks like a
ball
okay that's not what a quantum particle
is
quantum particle is an equation that
when you touch it when you try to
measure when you
put your little measuring stick meter
stick
towards it it occupies the entire
universe it's spread out
they call it a field you know value at
each point in space
so it's condensed and at the same time
spread out
they covered all the bases they had to
make sure that
they could cover all the bases for their
equations right
and so shorting here put what happens to
a micro subatomic particle in macro
world terms
that's what he did okay he said look
this is what the
copenhagen guys are doing i'm gonna do
it with my cat
the cat is both dead and alive until you
open the box in other words until you
see you observe you measure you detect
sodium wants you to understand how
absurd the physical interpretations of
quantum mechanics are
so it's not only uh you know
the coherence it's not only entanglement
action not a distance without a mediator
black magic
i call it okay it's uh it's not um
superposition the fact that you have
these that on the one hand it's uh
oh hold on let me get something here
give me a second
okay folks i got uh some big problem
here
major problem i'm gonna have to cut it
short today
so i will see you next time i wasn't
able
let me finish here uh you'll hear my
voice in the background but i got
i got lost i'm not here anymore i'll
just give you my conclusions of this
okay as a final thing it's uh
and this conclusion are all quantum
physical interpretations decoherence
entanglement superposition
complementarity and uncertainty are
all irrational sugar schrodinger devised
an
analogy in macro terms okay to ridicule
boroscope and higgin interpretation it's
called known as
schrodinger's cat analogy you could call
it okay
despite the blatant attack on the
copenhagen interpretation on rationality
most mathematical physicists today
physicist with quotation there
subscribe to it that's what people
believe this is what they explain out
there
what does this say about the mental
capacity of mathematical physicists
to elucidate the workings of the
universe
should you believe in them should you
put your hand in the fire for these
people when they cannot tell you
they cannot tell you uh you know what uh
they cannot explain to you any of these
phenomena because they can't see it they
cannot observe it they talk about
observing being part of the
scientific method of physics and here
they cannot observe but they still
give you interpretation so why do they
why do they give you physical
interpretations
if they cannot if they cannot
uh first if they dismiss them as
philosophy and then if they cannot
observe any ways so this is the issue
the issue is that
these people are giving you selling you
nonsense
and when you put them against the ropes
and start battling them
saying hey by the way what you're
telling me is nonsense they say well we
know it's nonsense but that's philosophy
anyways
anyways i'll see you next time hopefully
on sunday